So the only allele combination in this list
that should show signs of lactose intolerance would
be the cytosine cytosine combination, or the CC.
And the reason is because. Remember that the
[INAUDIBLE]
causes non lactase persistence, right? We need lactase
to digest lactose. Without it, we'll be lactose intolerant.
So if we have 2 cytosines, then, obviously. We're
probably going to show symptoms of lactose intolerance. But if
we have one copy of the T allele, right
if we have a cytosine and some thiamine. One
copy by itself is enough to produce some lactase
into adulthood. This presumably would be enough to mitigate
any effects of lactose intolerance, right cause now we're
going to have some lactase around we can digest our
lactose. If it's digested, then we're not going to
show those symptoms of lactose intolerance. So even one
copy is enough to not be lactose intolerance. And
of course, having two copies of the T allele
would also most likely make you not show signs
of lactose intolerance, because then you'd have plenty of lactase.